I don't understand this question and
you're gonna have to take me to school
on this one summarize the timelessness
of a photon Oh beautiful
I'm ready are you ready I'm ready for
this no you're not really you sound like
Beyonce okay are you ready for this
tell me are you ready already I know you
know I'm not ready no tell me again
okay I'm ready alright you should know
if you study relativity Einstein's
relativity great then as you increase
your speed time takes more slowly for
you than it does for anyone who's
watching you right alright this is the
relativity of time this is well known
we've measured this this is not it
it's not just your clock that's ticking
slower your metabolism is unfolding more
more slowly your brain synapses firing
more slowly everything about you is
slowing down all right as you travel
faster and faster get closer and closer
to the speed of light you age more and
more and more slowly time takes more and
more slowly for you ok if you hit the
speed of light which we don't know how
to do yet but if you ever hit the speed
of light then time stop stops photons
which is the carrier of what nice right
exists at the speed of light it doesn't
accelerate from zero to speed of light
in 3.4 seconds correct it exists at the
speed of light and because it exists at
the speed of light any watch that it's
carrying never ticks which means if you
are the photon become the photon if you
aren't it's not a proton now all right
particle in the nucleus of an atom
thought on the part of my light if you
are a photon and you are emitted from
across the universe you will be absorbed
but you will slam into whatever you are
destined to hit as far as you are
concerned
it's instantaneously that's correct
right there's no time whatever no time
is great because you can't because at
that speed
where
you exist that speed time has stopped
stop so for you time doesn't exist time
does not exist did this is mind blow I'm
just not exist hi young man okay now
here's now not waiting man you got to
give me a second man you gotta absorb
that now that was great no no I got some
weed I need some weed that was cool
some people would have requested it in
advance so so it's why we knew that the
neutrino could not be traveling at the
speed of light because the neutrino
actually changes species Midway that's
there's one kind of neutrino they can
become a different kind of moves
neutrinos species how would it know to
do that unless it's keeping track of
time exactly it knew to do this it does
that at a predictable interval it can
only do that if it's carrying a clock a
stopwatch Wow
so we knew the neutrinos were not
travels inside our heads because if they
were they would never change